supercomputing on a phone copyright MIT
fabri 11 2010 by photo/david knezevic
and Tony pedorra with contributions from
many colleagues we consider transient
heat conduction in a cube consisting of
eight sub Q but different connectivities
the conductivity of the first sub cube
is set to unity the normalized
connectivities of the remaining seven
sub Q biscayne be chosen between 0.5 and
2.0 in this first instance the
connectivities are all unity except the
second sub tube which has a conductivity
of 0.5 we set the reduced basis
dimension to 10 and solve initially the
temperature is zero a flux is then
applied at the bottom boundary the four
outputs correspond to the average
temperature as a function of time in
small subdomains near the four corners
of the heated surface we focus on the
second output which measures the
temperature in the second in this case
low conductivity sub Q the second output
is represented in the plot by the red
lines the dark red line is the
inexpensive reduced basis output
prediction computed online by the phone
the two light red lines are the
inexpensive reduced basis output bounds
also predicted online by the phone it
can be proven that these two light red
lines rigorously bound the output
prediction we would have obtained had we
performed a super computer calculation
an expensive very high resolution highly
accurate simulation on a proper machine
our reduced basis error the gap between
the light red lines is clearly too large
we now increase the reduced basis
dimension to 45 and solve again we must
now wait slightly longer for the phone
to compute the reduced basis result we
see that the gap between the dark red
line and the two light red lines is now
deemed acceptable small hence
supercomputing on a phone more precisely
the equivalent of supercomputing on a
phone we may now visualize the result we
present results for the temperature as a
function of time on the cube surface
lower conductivity regions such as the
second sub cube result in higher
temperatures represented here by the red
isotherms we may now change the
parameters the reference conductivity in
the first sub cube remains unity we set
the conductivity in the second sub cube
to two point
zero and the conductivity in the six
remaining sub tubes to 0.5 we again
solve but now for these new values of
the seven parameters we may vary the
parameters in real time here on the
phone but more generally an embedded and
deployed context limitations apply
offline costs for the development of new
data sets can be considerable this
application is not appropriate for small
children or other individuals and
experience with partial differential
equations